[Music]
well good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the battle in Congress
of the border wall is still ongoing is
you know now into its third week large
swaths of government remains shut down
trash remains on the ground the
president says though he will not give
in until he gets funding for a border
wall the president plans to address the
country tomorrow night that he's gonna
travel to the Mexican border later this
week to make his case on the Democratic
side meanwhile the battle lines remain
exactly in place as they were last week
they can't allow wall to be built under
any circumstances they've said so many
times mainly because of the risk it
might actually secure the border they
can't say that out loud
needless to say so they have other story
lines you know how those go they argue
that because walls have worked well for
thousands of years somehow they won't
work now if we're talking about border
security the overwhelming number of
undocumented people in the United States
overstayed visas they did not cross the
border the solution to that is not a
concrete wall this wall is no determined
by proposing a fifth-century solution in
terms of this medieval bought a wall for
21st century problem we don't think the
wall is a good technology to do the
objective possible that's a coordinated
talking point just guessing in case it
doesn't work here's another talking
point walls are just immoral whether
they work or not the inference that you
draw from wall is that the only way to
do that that actually is an immorality
it builds walls within people's minds
about who should come here and the rest
it's a very sad thing I hate the way I
think it Seymour I think it's wasteful
how are we a country that puts a wall
between ourselves and an allied nation a
wall is an immoral symbol for our
country in case you're keeping track on
your morality chart at home walls are
moral more than moral in fact laudable
when they're bored built in Jordan or
Israel or Tunisia with American backing
when they're built here to protect our
own population they are immoral okay
that's argument number two here's
argument number three popular with cable
news creations I correct Wilson anybody
who supports the wall is inbred
the idea of a physical wall it Donald
Trump loves selling this to his base and
again these are people who are not
sophisticated they are not bright they
do not understand the complexity okay
here we're going again now with here we
go with with condescending to us in the
Trump yeah its complexity its kind of
people who aren't Wilson just wouldn't
understand they're on intellectuals like
Rick Wilson that's what he's telling you
on CNN those are the arguments